[Musique]
bien dans le débat sur France 24 il y a
5 ans des milliers de femmes écrivaient
hashtag me to pour témoigner de
violences sexuelles dont elles avaient
été l'objet c'était quelques jours après
l'enquête du New York Times et du New
Yorker sur Harvie wine Steen le
producteur sera condamné à 23 ans de
réclusion pour agression sexuelle et
viol en quelques heures le hashtag
devient viral un mouvement féministe
mondial est né cinq ans après quel est
l'impact finalement encore du mouvement
me too quel est l'ampleur du phénomène
quid du principe de la présomption
d'innocence justice est-elle rendue aux
femmes victimes et bien on va en
débattre avec mes invités j'ai le
plaisir d'avoir à mes côtés
Axel jeune gicquet bonsoir vous êtes
autrice afro afro PN dit-on maintenant
aujourd'hui podcasteuse autrice de
journal intime d'une féministe et c'est
aux éditions Au diable vauvert bienvenue
à vous en face de vous Sophie Obadia
bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes avocate
pénaliste au barreau de Paris bienvenue
à vous également Muriel réussi bonsoir
vous êtes fondatrice et présidente de
femmes avec et vice-présidente également
de Me Too Media vous avez contribué
enfin vous voulez contribuer à
l'améliorer à Sion de la place et du
respect des femmes dans la société
bienvenue à vous en face de vous Sabine
procoris bonsoir vous êtes philosophe
psychanalyste auteur de Le Mirage
hashtag me too essai aux éditions du
Cherche-Midi bienvenue à toutes les
quatre dans ce débat avant d'en débattre
on va revenir justement sur cette
affaire cette affaire winstin à faire
qui a donc fait naître le mouvement me
too avec Claire base d'Arrée Beach et
Julie Chouteau
Claudie kanvouter le visage des fées le
6 janvier 2020 s'étendait ambulateur
carvet Wayne Steen arrive à la Cour
suprême de New York diminuée par une
opération du dos en fait-il trop pour
apitoyer les jurés certains le pensent à
l'extérieur du tribunal de Manhattan des
manifestants sont là pour soutenir les
victimes parmi elles des actrices comme
Rose Magoa ou Rosanna Arquette
le temps du harcèlement sexuel au
travail est terminé on ne peut plus
blâmer les victimes et ça suffit avec
les excuses bidon sans conséquence
Harvey weinsteen est accusé d'agression
sexuelle par 80 femmes mais à son procès
seul deux accusatrices mimi haylée
ancienne assistante de production et
Jessica man aspirant actrice quatre
autres femmes sont appelées à la barre
dont l'actrice Annabella ciora la
défense est offensive agressive sur
place les témoins décrivent un Harvey
Wayne Steen serein le producteur de 67
ans refuse de témoigner plaide son
innocence mais le 24 février il est
déclaré coupable et Coop de 23 ans de
prison ferme à l'annonce du verdict
l'accusé fait un malaise le lendemain
une douzaine de féministes réunis devant
le tribunal salue une décision
historique la première de l'ermite ou
ce verdict doit servir d'exemple pour
que tous les survivants soient entendus
et crus et pour que tous les prédateurs
soient condamnés en justice
Harvey Wayne a fait appel de sa peine
qu'il purgea Rikers Island une prison
parmi les plus dangereuses au monde
qu'ils quitte temporairement pour
comparaître à Los Angeles dans une autre
affaire de viol son procès californien
devrait s'ouvrir d'ici la mi-novembre
c'est intéressant de le revoir à 20 ans
après 5 ans après pardon Muriel
n'ont pas encore 20 ans vous avez été
victime de PPDA le présentateur du JT de
TF1 vous faites partie des 30 femmes qui
l'ont accusé d'agressions sexuelles ou
de viol dans votre cas c'est agression
sexuelle contrairement à Hélène devin
qui a donc qui vient de publier un livre
qui elle en fait à porter plainte pour
viol et elle dénonce d'ailleurs
l'impunité du présentateur elle dénonce
un système qu'est-ce qui vous a poussé à
parler Muriel Reus est-ce que c'est
justement cet effet Mitou moi ce qui m'a
poussé à parler c'est un moi j'ai voulu
témoigner du fait que
la direction et la présidence de TF1
étaient au courant parce que je l'avais
moi-même prévenu donc il m'a semblé
important si vous voulez à un moment
donné de dire de soutenir la parole de
ces femmes que je ne connaissais pas on
se connaît maintenant bien sûr mais on
se connaissait pas une trentaine c'est
ça 30 femmes aujourd'hui le chiffre
exact c'est 33e année 33 témoignages et
21 plaintes je regarde mes chiffres
parce que tous les jours toujours les
chiffres changent et 21 plaints donc moi
il m'a semblé important à un moment
donné de dire voilà oui il y a
effectivement des faits et puis il y a
une responsabilité en tout cas une
responsabilité d'entreprise à ce
moment-là qui n'a pas été de enfin qui a
été de ne pas considérer qu'il pouvait
se passer des choses sur lesquelles on
pouvait s'interroger tous les soirs dans
les locaux de cette chaîne à l'époque
moi j'étais dirigeante d'une filiale de
TF1 donc voilà j'ai pensé que ma parole
pouvait être importante dans ce combat
qui était le leur et qui est devenu le
lien Hélène Devinck justement qui est
écrit évoque le coût du plateau c'est ce
qui vous est arrivé vous le coût du
plateau oui enfin moi c'est un peu
particulier parce que si vous voulez moi
je
l'avais des fonctions dans cette filiale
et c'est vrai qu'un jour ça se critère
m'a appelé pour venir sur ce JT j'étais
très surprise j'ai pas très bien compris
ça demande et ça démarche d'ailleurs je
ne suis pas allé la première fois
j'avais dit oui j'ai oublié d'y aller à
quel point ça m'intéressait d'aller
assister à un JT en direct et le
lendemain c'est un assistante m'a appelé
une seconde fois vous proposer de
revenir bon j'ai trouvé que c'était un
peu impoli de payer les deux fois donc
effectivement il s'est passé ce qui
s'est passé avec beaucoup de femmes
c'est à dire une présence derrière les
caméras et ensuite être accompagné dans
ce bureau à c’était ma maison donc j'ai
pas du tout un semblant d'inquiétude sur
quoi que ce soit et puis effectivement
son comportement inadapté pour le moment
c'est ce qu'on peut dire oui quoi parce
que qu'est-ce qu'il a fermé à clé c'est
ce que vous aviez raconté ce secrétaire
est parti à fermer la porte qui m'a
surprise parce que effectivement dans la
maison de fermer jamais les portes en
tout cas pas les présidents de cette
boîte et puis deux secondes après il a
fermé la porte à clé et puis c'est
l'enlever son pantalon il s'est retrouvé
en caleçon en deux secondes donc comment
avez-vous réagi comment voulez-vous
réagir moi j'ai trouvé ça j'ai eu un
instant stupéfaction quand même en me
demandant ce qui se passait
et puis je lui ai dit que Melia avec la
direction étant donné mes liens avec la
présidente de cette entreprise c'était
assure surprenant qu'il se retrouve dans
cette situation là ça s'est arrêté très
vite donc il s'est rhabillé et il m'a
raccompagné à et vous a prévenu la
direction de TF1 ce dimanche Hélène
Devinck dit dénoncer un système c'est ça
en fait c'est vraiment l'abus de pouvoir
dont on parle là finalement on peut
faire un parallèle avec l'affaire
winstin moi je pense moi je pense que
l'affaire PPDA est le plus gros mytho
français en tout cas en terme de
dénonciation en terme de plainte en
terme de reconduction si vous voulez
d'un système très organisé avec des
gestes des propos des mots des
interrogations qui ont tout le temps été
les mêmes depuis toutes ces années
d'ailleurs on parle de sérénité
aujourd'hui donc même si les procureurs
s'interrogent sur cette notion là je
sais que il y a un fondement en tout cas
ce que l'on constate c'est que
énormément de femmes qui ne se
connaissent pas décrivent un même
système et que même le major en charge
l'enquête a conclu avec des mots qui
étaient celui d'un céréales agresseur
Axel johndi qui est pour vous qu'est-ce
que ça a entraîné justement me too vous
avez écrit ce livre il me semble qu'il
est assez récent en tout cas il a été
publié récemment c'est en fait votre
histoire c'est la vie d'une femme qui
est devenue mère qui a souffert de
violences sexuelles éducatif dans
l'enfance est-ce que c'est ce mouvement
Mitou qui vous a poussé à écrire ce
livre alors moi le mouvement me too et
antérieur à la date qu'on donne
là on est sur les 5 ans du mouvement me
too médiatique il faut savoir que le
mouvement a 15 ans qu'il a été créé en
2007 par une activiste noire américaine
qui s'appelle Tarana Burke et nous ce
que on célèbre aujourd'hui c'est ce qui
s'est passé avec Alyssa Milano qui est
dans un premier temps a donc envoyé ce
hashtag en pensant
en souhaitant en tout cas rallier des
femmes autour d'elle sans savoir que
c'était déjà un mot d'ordre au sein
d'une association qui avait créé Tarana
Burke qui s'appelait me too
parce que elle avait elle-même été
victime de violence sexuelle dans
l'enfance et dans sa jeunesse et elle
avait été interpellé en 1996 par une
jeune femme de 12 ans qui s'appelle
Heaven qui lui rapportait qu'elle
suivait qu'elle subissait des viols
success de la part de son beau-père et
Tarana beurre qui avait alors 22 ans et
qui était juste animatrice dans ce
centre de vacances n'a pas trouvé les
ressources
en elle pour pouvoir dire à la petite
moi aussi et donc le fameux MiTo le midi
de ça et c'est avant tout un mouvement
qui porte sur le soutien que les
victimes les personnes victimes ça porte
les unes aux autres c'est pas un
mouvement qui est centré sur les
agresseurs c'est d'abord un mouvement de
soutien entre les femmes et je tenais
vraiment à recontextualiser ça parce
qu'aujourd'hui qu'on parle trop des
agresseurs et pas assez des victimes je
trouve qu'on oublie de mentionner
qu'effectivement les le propos c'est pas
pardon mais quelle réaction
Murielle à ce moment-là
quel comportement a eu en face son
agresseur et je et pardon mais
effectivement je trouve que on met la
focale beaucoup beaucoup sur les
agresseurs à juste titre mais il faut
aussi savoir que c'est un mouvement qui
donne de la force aux personnes qui sont
victimes nous ne sommes pas des pauvres
petites choses fragiles machin c'est un
peu ce que vous disiez aussi
quand on parle de cette 33 femmes
solidarité féminine une solidarité
extraordinaire c'est le cœur même de ce
mouvement en fait Sophie Obadia
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez vous qui
êtes l'avocate de ce plateau d'abord on
parle beaucoup de la libération de la
parole des femmes ça va avec cette
solidarité que décrit justement Axel moi
j'interviens dans le dans l'enceinte
judiciaire et en réalité cette sororité
là que vous évoquez n'existe pas pour
les magistrats c'est à dire que chaque
dossier est individuel il peut arriver
qu'il y ait des plaintes collectives
mais c'est plutôt rare en fait pas
collectif individuel vous avez raison
donc il s'additionnent donc ça devient
une affaire importante parce qu'il y a
aussi de très nombreuses plaignantes
mais ce n'est pas sous cet angle que la
justice considère le mouvement Mitou au
contraire elle elle reste dans sa sphère
en se disant il y a du bruit dehors il y
a du bruit dans la cité j'entends ce qui
se dit quels sont les débats quels sont
effectivement vraiment les remous que
constitue ce mouvement mais en aucun cas
la justice ne l'envisage sous cet angle
en disant nous nous ne sommes pas du
tout un groupe de parole il y aura pas à
l'audience un moment très important
donné aux plaignantes on peut le pleurer
ou pas mais parce que en fait si on peut
le déplorer mais il faut connaître nos
traditions juridiques en France et et là
j'entends bien que c'est un mouvement
anglo-saxon la tradition juridique
française je le dis en tant pénaliste et
focalisé sur l'auteur le procès pénal
est d'abord le procès d'un auteur ou
d'une hauteur si c'est une femme mais
mais ça c'est d'abord le procès de
l'accusé et aujourd'hui avec le
mouvement MiTo dans ma sphère
d'intervention je cons qu'effectivement
il y a une poussée des plaignantes et
des parties civils mais l'institution
judiciaire continue à focaliser sur
l'auteur des faits présumés ou en tout
cas mise en examen et puis accusé ou
prévenus on va y revenir Sabine
procorize vous votre livre s'appelle le
mirage me tour et vous avez d'ailleurs
signé une tribune vous également Sophie
aubadia dans Marianne disant que la
tournure que prend le mouvement Mitou
vous inquiétez parce que vous estimez
qu'il menace finalement notre éditif
notre édifice démocratique alors en quoi
alors qu'on parle de libération de la
parole bien déjà bon il y a plusieurs
remarques que je pourrais faire pour
vous répondre en passant par tout ce qui
a été dit d'abord vous avez commencé en
vous adressant à Madame Reus en disant
vous avez été victime déjà pour moi ça
c'est un problème ce n'est pas que je
veux mettre en doute votre récit votre
version votre véhicule votre ressenti
mais on ne peut pas
avant tout avant un jugement dire à
quelqu'un dire publiquement que
quelqu'un a été victime ça veut dire que
par définition la personne mise en cause
et coupable et c'est un défendement de
Mito je le sais puisque un des slogans
on peut dire demi-tour c'est victime en
vous croit ça c'est une chose d'autre
part donc c'est le principe de
présomption d'innocence
qui est évidemment non seulement un
principe de la procédure pénale mais
également un des principes de la
Déclaration universelle des droits de
l'Homme de 1948 et de la déclaration
européenne des droits de l'homme de
européenne l'autre chose je tiens un peu
surprise d'une chose que vous avez dites
madame en disant qu'il me semble un peu
contradictoire avec beaucoup de choses
que j'ai pu lire
d'une part vous jolie partout que tout
le monde savait en ce qui concerne PPDA
et d'autre part j'entends que vous qui
étiez à TF1 depuis avec des fonctions
depuis si longtemps vous étiez surprise
que ça vous ne n'étiez pas vous ne vous
doutiez de rien donc pour moi une petite
discordance cognitive mais bon si vous
permettez oui
c'est un terme de victimes vous avez
raison il ne convient à personne ben non
mais c'est pas la question qui convienne
à personne
je dis pas que revendiquer ou non d'être
une victime je parle du statut de
victime c'est pas de ça que je pense on
peut discuter là oui mais non ce statut
il est défini par Alice à l'issue du
procès ça c'est une chose deuxièmement
ce que vous disiez vous madame sur je
sais très bien comment ça que ça a
débuté il y a bien plus longtemps mais
que à ce moment-là ça n'a eu aucun effet
que c'est à partir d'Hollywood que les
choses ont commencé à aimer enfin
vraiment en tout cas phénomène un
phénomène de masse mais quand même le la
réaction de cette éducatrice je suis
très surprise de ce que vous dites quand
vous dites elle a pas pu lui dire moi
aussi mais la question c'était pas de
lui dire moi aussi c'était de d'emmener
cette petite fille
à la police de dénoncer les faits et de
protéger de cette façon là cette petite
je vois pas en quoi ça la protégeait de
dire moi aussi 10 ans plus tard en plus
bon ça c'est une chose alors maintenant
pour ce que vous dites oui pourquoi j'ai
écrit et maintenant sur ce que vous
disiez oui je pense qu'il y a un mirage
parce que je pense que la cause est
évidemment parfaitement fondamentale
c'est-à-dire la question du harcèlement
sexuel des des du sexisme et des
infractions sexuelles ce sont des
questions tout à fait fondamentales ce
qui me paraît intéressant avec le
mouvement MiTo si vous voulez c'est que
la question féministe est revenue sur le
sur le sur le sur le sur la table alors
depuis des années elle était assez mise
de côté il me semble maintenant à partir
du moment où on est dans cette logique
d'un mouvement de masse avec un certain
type de un appareil théorique si vous
voulez la culture du viol le continuum
de VSS comme on dit aujourd'hui etc je
crois qu'il y a un vrai problème de si
vous voulez de confusion initiale et je
crois que ça la cause des femmes mûre
parce que peut-être que ce n'est pas
votre intention madame le fait de me
dire ça c'est comme si vous me mettez en
cause ce que je viens de dire non mais
je m'interroge vous me laissez vous
répondre interrogez-vous interrogez-vous
comme les 30 femmes qui ont porté
plainte et celles qui ont témoignait ce
que je dis en tant que présidente en
tout cas nous parlons c'était pas
président j'étais directrice générale
adjoint de cette filiale ce que je dis
c'est que je ne sais pas si tout le
monde savait ce n'est pas ce que j'ai
dit tout à l'heure je ne sais pas parce
que moi je n'étais pas tous les jours
non non mais peut-être que vous l'avez
vu en tout cas moi je ne l'ai pas dit ce
que j'ai dit simplement c'est que
personne s'est interrogé à un moment
dans cette organisation qui était TF1
qui n'était pas la mienne parce que
j'étais directrice d'une filiale et je
ne passais pas ma vie à TF1 personne ne
s'est interrogé sur le fait que tous les
soirs les jeunes femmes étaient dans ce
bureau jusqu'à 21h et 21h30 tous les
soirs personne s'est interrogé là-dessus
c'est de la responsabilité d'une
entreprise que de s'interroger sur la
sécurité de ses salariés c'est ça que
j'ai dit et c'est ça que je l'ai dit à
la présidence et quand j'ai appelé la
président si vous me laissez aller au
bout de cette démarche quand j'ai appelé
Patrick Lelay qui était président de
cette entreprise sa première réaction a
été de dire il n'a quand même pas osé
aussi avec toi alors qu'est-ce que le
osé voulait dire je ne sais pas je ne
dis pas qu'il savait pour les viols je
ne me permettraient jamais de dire ça
comme je me permettrais pas de dire que
quelqu'un à TF1 savait pour des viols en
tout cas il y avait une interrogation
très forte
et cette phrase la confirme sur qui
pouvait se passer dans ce bureau mais je
pense qu'on va pas passer toutes les
missions là-dessus non Axel qui est
justement sur pour répondre à Madame
procoriste sur justement cette histoire
de justice pourquoi effectivement elle
n'emmène pas l'enfant tout de suite voir
le juge il y a on se chez les victimes
vous divisez pas le terme mais il y a
toujours cette espèce d'appréhension
d'aller voir le juge on le voit
d'ailleurs il y a ces problèmes
d'ailleurs de prescription de fait
puisque souvent les femmes portent
plainte très tard votre
sentiment là-dessus je pense que c'est
très mal connaître les mécanismes qui se
mettent en branle quand on suit une
agression là elle était pas un endroit
où elle pensait le juge elle pensait
d'abord à ce que ça répercuté on aide ce
que la petite est en train de raconter
donc quel problème à ses sensations donc
pardon madame mais il faut avoir été
terminé
et donc le fait que ça réactive chez
elle ce traumatisme là ne lui a même pas
permis d'écouter la jeune femme qui se
confie à elle jusqu'au bout et c'est
parce qu'elle a toujours eu sur la
conscience ce qui s'était passé à ce
moment-là parce qu'elle a regretté de ne
pas avoir fait ce qui était nécessaire
et je pense que ça va effectivement du
côté de la loi du côté de la justice
puisque aujourd'hui c'est ce que fait
son organisation c'est parce qu'elle a
pensé à ça que 10 ans plus tard elle
crémit tout et qu'elle permet
aujourd'hui à des millions de femmes
dans le monde déjà dans un premier temps
de reconnaître ce qu'elles ont vécu
au-delà de la justice et de ce que vous
pouvez penser de cette question là
pourquoi est-ce que la porte 80% des
femmes ne portent pas plainte 80% des
femmes parce qu'il y a des mécanismes
qui ne nous permettent pas de le faire
parce que déjà dans il faut déjà le la
première le premier endroit où l'on
parle en fait c'est dans notre entourage
et déjà rien qu'en voyant les réactions
des entourage vous êtes pas forcément
incité à aller porter plainte faut avoir
du jus pour aller porter plainte c'est
ce que dit Hélène de vague d'ailleurs
dans son dans son bouquin ça veut dire
qu'il y a aucun problème avec cette
justice enfin qui est quoi éloigné
la justice ne peut pas soutenir et
considérer que elle va rentrer dans les
foyers donc la difficulté qu'il y a à
porter plainte et à suivre le parcours
du combattant de la combattante c'est
une évidence vous dites le parcours du
combattant mais évidemment
dans son livre ça reste le parcours du
combattant et distribuellement
interminable pour plaignante et que
c'est très long ça nous en sommes tous
d'accord et ça devrait changer je pense
que cette prise en compte du temps qui
passe et qui détruit parce qu'en même
temps il faut se reconstruire il faut
dépasser ce qu'on a subi tout en en
parlant constitue une difficulté qui va
falloir dépasser et la justice doit s'en
occuper pour autant pour autant quand
vous parlez de l'entourage aujourd'hui
c'est à mon avis l'apport de Me Too il
est là c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui une
plaignante une jeune fille une jeune
femme d'âme un jeune homme aussi parce
qu'il y a une maman qui dit voilà il
m'est arrivé ça j'en ai défendu pour qui
ça a été atroce d'en parler à leur
famille parce qu'ils avaient
l'impression parfois de parler d'un
oncle d'un grand-père et que ça allait
tout détruire donc aujourd'hui ce
mouvement a une vertu essentielle c'est
de pouvoir parler en ayant en face de
soi des gens qui en ont entendu parler
et qui ne sont pas complètement voyez
tomber de l'armoire en disant c'est pas
possible ça n'arrive pas chez nous si ça
arrive partout donc ça c'est un bienfait
en revanche je continue à dire que là où
il faut assister ardemment et je rejoins
Sabine procurus c'est que c'est la
justice qu'il faut d'abord la police
évidemment mais à la justice qu'il faut
d'abord penser c'est à dire que garder
pour soi longtemps après venir avec des
accusations dont on pourra difficilement
dire si elles sont vraies fondées parce
que beaucoup de choses auront disparu
des traces de plein de choses il faut
parler le plus vite possible et à
l'autorité de ce qu'on appelle
il y a un terme pour ça justement les
femmes qui oublient en fait deviennent
amnés
cette espèce de traumatisme qui fait que
justement on peut pas parler et qui fait
que effectivement les femmes souvent
parlent beaucoup trop tard Sabine
progress c'est vrai que vous parlez de
quelque chose de trop sacré peut-être
avec MiTo mais est-ce que ça pousse pas
effectivement cette libération de la
parole elles vont finir par aller saisir
le juge parler
de votre terme de sacré mais vous n'avez
pas tort c'est devenu une sorte de
religion moi je vous le disais pas il me
semble que j'avais
en fait ce qui me gêne surtout c'est
l'équivalent
[Musique]
qui en a rien à faire avec un viol
quelconque ni même avec une atteinte
physique puisque Sandra Muller avait
reçu une gifle quelques années enfin
elle n'en n'a jamais parlé jamais porté
plainte c'était la phrase grossière dans
cette explique excuse c'est pas que j'ai
fait un programme
et le lendemain alyssa Milano tout ça
c'est vraiment conne aussi c'est un
mouvement de solidarité féminine
peut-être de sororité je ne dis pas le
contraire d'un type particulier quand
même mais ça concerne aussi l'idée que
si on se sent ou qu'on est victime c'est
pas forcément la même chose et bien il y
a donc des agresseurs des prédateurs
voilà alors sur l'amnésie traumatique
rapidement rapidement parce que je
voudrais qu'elle interviennent aussi
justement
permettrait de réaliser rapidement alors
je ne vous réponds en tant que psy bien
entendu que l'amnésie traumatique
l'emprise la sidération sont des
phénomènes qui existent la sidération
seulement la manière dont ils sont
employés aujourd'hui y compris dans la
justice à partir de théorie de la
victimologie traumatique notamment de
Muriel Salmona mais elle n'est pas la
seule sont absolument discutables d'un
point de vue psy d'un point de vue
scientifique et notamment sur la
question de la mémoire parce que d'abord
ça revient très souvent avec les moyens
très important parce que il peut arriver
que quelque chose qu'un flash de quelque
chose remonte d'abord moi ce que j'ai vu
dans ma dans ma patientèle si vous
voulez de femmes qui ont subi des
incestes ou des viols elle s'en
souviennent il peut y avoir en général
des pans qui soient oubliés par-ci
par-là mais on se souvient des
événements après l'amnésie traumatique
en tant que telle ça peut arriver
seulement quand les choses reviennent
contrairement à ce que dit Madame
Salmona on n'est pas comme elle le dit
téléporter dans le passé peuvent être
prescrits
ce qui revient et coloré par le moment
présent parce qu'on est aujourd'hui et
aussi par une ambiance donc ça très
fragile si vous voulez à ce moment-là on
peut pas se fonder là-dessus vous pouvez
peut-être répondre quand on parle de
prédateur c'est vrai que c'est un terme
qui est
un vrai problématique sur la formation
je pense qu'on a à peu près résolu le
problème sur les gendarmes et sur les
insensibilité parce que tout le monde
est formé aujourd'hui en revanche ça
veut dire ça c'est l'impact MiTo sur la
formation on a formé tous les gendarmes
on a formé toujours lui les policiers il
peut toujours y avoir des erreurs bien
sûr mais en tout cas les gens sont
formés et ont compris que c'était
important très positif après il y a la
justice quand vous avez 70%, 80 % des
affaires qui sont classées sans suite
quand vous avez 0,8% des affaires qui
sont portées devant la justice qui ne
qui ne sont pas enfin qui n'ont pas pour
lesquels il n'y a pas de jugement et
pour lesquels il n'y a pas de
condamnation ça pose un problème c'est à
dire que non seulement vous n'osez pas
parler parce que c'est extrêmement
compliqué mais quand vous parlez
il n'y a pas de condamnation ou très peu
qu'on a nation donc ça peut pas aider le
mouvement
ou pas c'est-à-dire que concrètement la
justice pénale de ce pays elle est
principalement
occupée par les affaires sexuels mais
c'est vrai mais 0,6 % pourquoi
c'est-à-dire que une affaire sur deux
devant les cours d'assises de province
ce sont des affaires d'inceste ou des
affaires de viol donc ça n'est pas un
nouveau phénomène que ce soit
judiciarisé ça existe depuis fort
longtemps et heureusement ce sont des
affaires qui sont traitées la difficulté
que nous avons c'est qu'aujourd'hui il y
a un afflux de plainte ça c'est une
certitude c'est aussi un des effets de
mitoon évidemment puisqu'on est quand
même sur le bilan donc ça veut dire que
les femmes d'orientation 30%
d'orientation
judiciaire comme celle qui que nous
avons en évidence qui est assez à peu
près le même nombre de magistrats qu'au
19ème siècle et un bout de la population
et un boom des plaintes donc
effectivement il y a un goulot
d'étranglement ça c'est la première
chose c'est certain et ça ne veut pas
dire qu'il y a un refus de prendre en
compte c'est qu'il y a une pile une pile
d'attente une pile d'attente qui n'en
finit plus et là où je rejoins Sabine
procoris c'est qu'en plus il n'y a plus
de distingo entre les faits c'est-à-dire
que ce fameux continuum entre une gifle
qui est une violence conjugale et un
viol sauf erreur de ma part il y a un
différence de niveau mais aujourd'hui il
y a un tel afflux et on est dans un
discours tellement diffus et peu
distinct en termes juridique que tout ça
vient s'empiler chez les juges sans
distinction de l'urgence et de la
gravité
0,6% de condamnation ce sont les
chiffres officiels mais moi je ne les
comprends pas je vous promets en toute
bonne regardez parce qu'il ne me
paraissent pas c'est pas possible en
réalité on prend un chiffre noir qui est
celui de celle qui aurait pu déposer
plainte mais par définition ne le
connais pas et le 0,6% n'est pas un
chiffre officiel c'est un chiffre qu'il
y a des associations militantes
le chiffre qui parle mais ce n'est pas
un chiffre qu'on peut calculer à partir
d'une base très sérieuse donc je ne m'a
moi je m'intéresse pas
de ministères
j'aimerais vraiment que vous les
interrogiez vous les regardiez
pas parce que
tout ça ça devient politique et qu'en
réalité on ne veut pas dire qu'on a pas
une justice à la haute valeur voilà moi
je vous l'envoie on est la tour on est
d'accord mais je ne m'en sers pas des
chiffres vous voyez ce que je veux vous
dire je vous parle du quotidien je vois
au quotidien des affaires qui traînent
des magistrats qui n'ont pas
nécessairement l'envie de s'occuper de
ça parce que nous on en parle
joyeusement de ça ce sont des vieilles
madame mais je comprenais que je vous
dis ça c'est un vieux ça mais c'est pas
donné de ma part moi je m'en occupe
toute la journée mais je vous dis que ça
n'est pas forcément très flatteur pour
les magistrats eux ils ont sentiments
que c'est la face cachée de la vie alors
que c'est la vie des gens effectivement
puisqu'encore une fois c'est une affaire
sur deux donc juste une réaction
peut-être que vous en avez parce que
vous avez beaucoup moins parlé pour moi
c'est le il s'agirait aussi de ne pas
circonscrire MiTo à l'aspect judiciaire
nous sommes aussi partie prenante en
termes de société dans ce qui est en
train de se passer donc la vérité c'est
que si on se met toutes à porter plainte
en fait la justice ne tiendra pas le
compte assuré c'est sûr et certain ce
qui est des gens qui est ce qui est déjà
le cas et donc
s'il y a pas la justice déjà est-ce que
on peut s'assurer dans nos familles dans
nos cercles dans nos communautés que ces
personnes victimes parce que je préfère
le terme personne victime au terme de
victimes parce que nous continuons à
fonctionner en dépit de cette agression
moi je suis une mère heureusement je
suis une amie je suis une compagne quand
je décide de l'être enfin j'ai une
multitude d'autres identités et je n'ai
pas que celle-là donc je suis une
personne victime je suis une personne à
qui a un instant une agression est
arrivée mais il faut dépasser la chose
chose là est aussi ce qui me permet
aujourd'hui d'être sur ce plateau et de
pouvoir apporter ma pierre à l'édifice
il s'agit pas de le déplacer
à un édifice alors mine de rien ça va
vous paraître ce que je vais vous dire
je pense quand même que on est
extrêmement
on croit encore extrêmement à notre
société quand on fait ce qu'on fait là
on vient parler et on vient vous vous
interpeller là dessus parce qu'on croit
encore qu'il y a moyen de vivre en
harmonie ensemble et de vivre autrement
parce qu'on croit encore que nos
familles nos cercles peuvent être faits
autrement que comme ça et on prend la
peine de venir dénoncer ça pour qu'on
puisse mieux vivre ensemble et que le
plaisir la justesse l'amour soit le
mieux partagé
la justice on n'est pas de s'intéresse
pas nous on ne s'intéresse pas la
justice ça c'est comment dire un mot
d'ordre avec lequel je ne pouvais pas
être d'accord que ce soit un fait de
société MiTo c'est une évidence que ce
soit l'éducation qui peut résoudre
justement
sur ce qu'on appelle ça de consentement
vous pouvez en dire un mot intéressant
parce qu'on parle d'éducation alors
justement ce terme qui est enfin moi
j'ai lu le livre de Camille Kushner et
elle parle donc le consentement c'est le
titre d'ailleurs de ce livre
effectivement il précède celui qui a mis
coucher elle parle du consentement donc
le consentement est-ce que c'est devenu
un terme par exemple qu'il faut utiliser
dans l'éducation peut-être des petits
garçons des petites filles est-ce que
consentement aujourd'hui c'est quelque
chose dont on pourra aller peut-être pas
y a 20 ans il est au cœur par exemple
voilà est-ce que ça c'est un vrai on va
essayer de d'en parler un petit peu
c'est pas très simple d'en parler non
très rapidement jusqu'à une remarque
fait sociétal etc moi je pense que c'est
un fait sociétal qui est pas un seul
homme sur ce plateau
trop long pour les plaignantes mais il
est très long aussi pour les causes
quand vous faites de la préventive parce
que on a dit que vous étiez sous
empreinte que vous aviez mis quelqu'un
sous emprise comme par exemple Jean-Luc
Lahaye qui a mis ses fans soi-disant
sous emprise soit il est mis en prison
mis sous emprise c'est pas un terme
juridique en prix je sais que ça a été
mis dans le Grenelle des violences
conjugales de même que l'incitation mais
je suis très très enfin comment dire
perplexe devant le fait que
l'institution judiciaire certainement
elle est très
affolée par tout ce qui se passe et elle
est pour d'une porosité extraordinaire à
des termes non je dis non juridique et
qui sont infiltrés même pas par un vrai
savoir si canality ou scientifique ou
psycho
c'est très important
mais le vocabulaire il est pauvre c'est
à dire autant vous parle d'emprise quand
vous lisez la motivation de Georges
tronc par exemple de la condamnation
l'emprise est définie juste comme le
fait que il était le supérieur
hiérarchique mais c'est pas ça une
relation d'emprise voyez il y a une
princesse
s'appelle le consentement alors revenons
sur le consentement vous savez que
l'Espagne a voté une loi sur le
consentement explicite etc etc mais
c'est quand même un problème par exemple
Maxime Cochard
spécifique c'est important les cas
spécifiques il est il a été blanchi mais
il reste un violeur pour son parti etc
parce que et malgré le fait qu'il ait
des preuves explicite de consentement
par écrit donc le problème c'est que
vous pouvez avoir un consentement tout à
fait explicite que vous pouvez donc vous
pouvez faire état quand vous êtes mis en
cause le problème c'est quoi c'est que
très facilement on pourra vous vous dire
oui mais ce consentement était extorquer
la personne était sous emprise etc etc
etc donc c'est infini donc le
consentement c'est une chose les désirs
s'en est une autre et c'est extrêmement
naïf en tout cas dans le champ
judiciaire c'est une chose mais dans le
champ des relations humaines la question
est des relations intimes la question du
consentement posée dans cette terre elle
est extrêmement piégée si vous voulez
un avocat de forme pour les auteurs de
violence madame
effectivement la subtilité de relation
à être ensemble Muriel russe vous
répondez justement sur ce côté piégé le
consentement vous c'est quelque chose au
contraire que vous je pense que c'est
enfin moi j'ai pas envie de dire merci
mouvement Mitou et en tout cas tous les
moments féministes qui ont qui se sont
succédés dans les années 68 70 80 ils
ont construit en venant ici d'ailleurs
je m'interrogeais je me disais c'est
quand même étonnant parce que finalement
ils ont construit la femme que je suis
c'est-à-dire avec toutes les décisions
que j'ai prises finalement toutes les
décisions que j'ai prises dans ma vie
vos décisions ont changé
toutes les décisions que j'ai prises
dans ma vie qui ont été décisions
structurantes de ne pas marier ne pas
avoir d'enfants ça voilà c'est des
décisions que j'ai prises m'a
verticalité mon engagement aujourd'hui
le fait de créer une association d'avoir
des postes à responsabilité dans des
boîtes et cetera tout ça finalement ça a
été construit c'est né des mouvements
féministes et donc je dis merci parce
que la femme que je suis aujourd'hui me
va bien voilà alors après sur le
consentement moi je pense que vous avez
mis tout et le consentement ça réinthort
ça interroge le rapport à l'autre voilà
ça interroge profondément le rapport à
l'autre le rapport de l'acceptation le
rapport du toucher le rapport de la
parole la rapport du sexe le rapport de
ce que j'autorise l'autre à faire est-ce
que moi j'autorise que je m'autorise à
faire avec l'autre c'est extrêmement
important et oui ça doit être enseigné
dans les écoles oui on doit apprendre
aux petites filles aux petits garçons le
respect oui on doit apprendre aux petits
garçons petites filles le consentement
tout ça c'est extrêmement important
je pense que c'est c'est une question
qui qui a trait à la qualité de sujets
en fait et je suis un peu au-delà du
consentement parce que je pense que le
vrai problème c'est que quand on est une
femme et qu'on fait part de son désir on
est encore dans une société où c'est
extrêmement mal vu consentir c'est
attendre que quelqu'un vous fasse part
de son désir et à ce moment-là vous vous
êtes en mesure on est toujours pas dans
une société où ça va de soi que nous
nous pouvons décider si nous voulons ou
pas et là la conversation qu'on a c'est
encore une fois mettre le désir des
agresseurs potentiels au centre de la
conversation le problème c'est bien pour
ça que la définition du viol en France
pose une difficulté puisqu'il le
consentement est présumé il n'existe pas
s'il y a une surprise s'il y a une
violence c'est comme s'il était présumé
donc ça pose une vraie question de la
définition mais là où je vous dis que
c'est beaucoup plus subtil et difficile
c'est qu'on le regarde se contentement
en tout cas dans les affaires sexuelles
après après c'est à dire une fois que
quelqu'un a dit je finalement je n'étais
pas d'accord oui ou voilà et donc ça
c'est très difficile
Macron il dit il dit lui le président
français nous ne voulons pas d'une
société de l'Inquisition la justice est
au tribunal que ça se passe donc là je
cite le président français
un mot là-dessus c'est-à-dire que on a
parlé de cette terminologie tribunal
médiatique qui commence à être un peu
inculé la difficulté c'est que il finit
par société de l'Inquisition
c'est-à-dire qu'en fait on a le droit et
je pense qu'on sera toutes d'accord de
se défendre c'est à dire que de n'avoir
pour prisme notamment médiatique que des
accusations que des soupçons et quand un
homme prend la parole pour se défendre
on dit ah attention il
use il abuse de sa position parce qu'il
est en train de se défendre ça je ne
peux pas l'accepter et là-dessus je
rejoins le président de la République
c'est-à-dire que effectivement si
quelqu'un est acc et qu'il ne l'est pas
d'ailleurs devant le tribunal mais
médiatiquement et je pense aux affaires
évidemment des écologistes et bien s'il
vient parler et se défendre il me semble
que c'est le minimum des droits qu'il a
parce que la présomption d'innocence est
en train de devenir finalement se vider
de son sens et aujourd'hui devient un
abus aussi de celui qui veut se défendre
donc les droits de la défense c'est le
pilier de la démocratie et ça il faut
l'accepter et puis
on est d'accord j'ai l'impression aussi
qu'on se dirige aujourd'hui vers une
sorte d'exception sexuelle du droit et
je pense que c'est un droit dérogatoire
au droit commun et je crois que c'est un
vrai problème vous imaginez j'en parlais
avec un ami juriste l'autre jour si 20
ans après vous dites ah bah non mais
cette maison je l'ai acheté mais en fait
j'étais sous emprise j'ai pas consenti
on vous rirait au nez mais
je sais mais je sais c'est pour ça que
je prends un exemple c'est une analogie
c'est un exemple absurde mais parce que
très souvent moi je le vois dans ma
clinique aussi un certain nombre
d'histoires qui de de femmes ou d'hommes
d'ailleurs mais plutôt des femmes pour
plein de raisons notamment liés au
contexte actuel revisite après coup leur
consentement et disent ah bah non en
fait je crois que j'étais pas
concentante donc qu'est-ce qu'on fait
avec ça ça existe
le président sur ce tribunal cette
société de l'Inquisition enfin il a
envoyé un terme qui est extrêmement
désobligeant pour les femmes c'est de
leur amener à cette société à cette
enfin l'acquisition c'était pour les
sorcières quand même donc si vous voulez
on l'a quand même extrêmement mal pris
je pense que ça n'apaise pas le débat
tous ces mots tous ces termes
n'apaissent pas le débat
avec un problème
c'est de dire quand une femme vient me
voir qu'elle est victime la première
réflexe que l'on a j'ai mis tous médias
ou ces femmes avec ce sont les deux
associations dont je m'occupe c'est de
les accompagner pour porter plainte les
accompagner au commissariat et de saisir
la justice c'est le premier la première
de nous attendre elle est là et là alors
après on s'interroge est-ce que ça
suffit ça suffit pas pour elle parce que
si vous êtes deux choses d'abord l'acte
judiciaire donc ça veut dire qu'on les
accompagne et puis après il y a tout
suivi psychologique il faut accompagner
ces femmes parce qu'elles ont besoin
donc si vous voulez c'est un processus
qui est très long et d'empathie profonde
et donc voilà
c'est vrai question qu'on peut se poser
c'est la justice toujours jolie
est-ce qu'il faudrait justement que les
faits ne soient pas prescrits au bout de
10 ans est-ce qu'il faudra allonger par
exemple prescription est-ce que ça c'est
un vrai sujet
30%
aller jusqu'à 30 donc on l'a déjà
beaucoup allongé beaucoup il a été
rallongé oh il faudrait la venge encore
sur mineur dans la mesure où c'est
quelque chose qui vous touche lorsque
vous êtes enfant et que la société vous
doit protection et que c'est quelque
chose qui va rester indélébile pour vous
pourquoi est-ce que l'agresseur ne
serait pas en mesure d'être jugé tout au
long de sa vie simplement pour
avoir port atteinte à l'enfance parce
que l'enfance devrait être quelque chose
de sacré pour nous tous pour nous tous
dans cette société nous devrions faire
quand autour des enfants et nous assurer
qu'ils passeront en tout cas l'enfance
dans de bonnes conditions donc si un
adulte franchement cette ligne là il est
en droit enfin je pense qu'on est en
droit de lui demander des comptes même à
la fin de sa vie
avec elle avec elle contre discours avec
et comment vous faites 35 40 ans 45 ans
après quand les témoins ne sont plus là
quand les personnes auxquelles a pu se
confier l'enfant ne sont pas là c'est ça
qu'il faut comprendre aussi c'est pas
que je veux gommer c'est pas que je veux
minimiser mais moi je veux un débat un
débat judiciaire sans c'est à dire
comment est-ce qu'on fait pour avoir des
c'est même pas des preuves parce que les
preuves quand il y a eu un faisable
donc il est acquitté c'est pire c'est
que c'est peut-être à ce moment là que
rentre en compte le collectif peut-être
qu'il y a d'autres accompagnements
d'autres dispositifs à mettre en route
en place pour que la justice ne se
retrouve pas saturée pour que il n'y ait
pas en deux mots qu'est-ce qui peut
remplacer écoute peut-être de cette
parole là la rente possible l'accueillir
l'accompagner tout du long mais alors
l'accueillir c'est très important
évidemment mais par contre c'est une
révolution de l'écoute en fait
l'écoute ça veut dire aussi la capacité
de décrypter ce que dit un enfant et
c'est très important ça veut pas dire de
dire qu'il ment mais de décrypter ce
qu'il dit quand même rappelons-nous on a
oublié le procès d'Outreau quand même
rappelons-nous le procès d'outro je
crois que c'est très important et
l'enfance il s'agit pas de dire
l'enfance les enfants
pour plein de raisons peuvent enfin il
n'y a pas d'ailleurs que ce qu'ils
disent il y a des tas de signes indiqués
on a le droit de le dire sans c'est
arrivé rappelez-vous l'histoire
français
il y a des enfants victimes et il y a
d'autres qui sont pour différentes
raisons
mis pris dans un discours dans des
rapports de force dans plein de choses
qui font que ils disent quelque chose
d'ailleurs il y a vous rappelez Loïc
c'est cher qui avait été condamné à
plusieurs années de prison pour viol
plusieurs années après il y a une
accusatrice qui s'est rétractée en
disant qu'elle avait menti il est sorti
de prison il serait resté éternellement
en prison je veux dire jusqu'au bout de
chapelle si elle ne s'était pas
rétractée c'est compliqué merci beaucoup
c'est compliqué ça c'est pour la vie
c'était un débat merci beaucoup d'y
avoir participé Axel jeune DJ merci
Sophia Obadia Sophie Obadia pardon merci
miche Muriel Reus Merci à VOUS Sabine
procoris et merci à vous tous de nous
avoir suivi c'est tout pour cette
émission restez avec nous sur France 24
[Musique]